what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven spoiler video before we get
started I want to make this very clear
this video contains major spoilers and
leaks that may potentially reveal what
will happen during an entire episode
this season I have no idea how much of
this will be true or not but if you
don't want anything spoiled by hearing
this leak I would recommend stopping the
video right now I know most people are
very skeptical about leaks which I am
too when it comes to certain ones but it
appears that the original plot leaked is
almost 100 percent accurate so hopefully
some of you are a little bit more
open-minded with leaks now I try not to
rule anything out until I see enough
evidence to prove it right or wrong but
what this league I'm about to show you
I'm still unsure of how much of this is
going to be true some of it has already
been confirmed by photos promos and
trailers but some of it is still unknown
I'm going to be honest with you right up
front some of this leaks sounds pretty
damn crazy in fact while I was making
this video I had to stop myself and ask
myself if I wanted to finish making the
video or not so I ran a poll on Twitter
and I asked all of my twitter followers
if they wanted me to make this video and
the majority of you said yes so here it
is first I got to give a shout out to
White's King on Twitter for sending me
this information the leak was originally
uploaded on a channel called freaky
doctor as far as I know it's a Spanish
Channel but someone translated the
entire video and posted the translation
I'm going to put the link to his channel
down below and I will put the link to
the translated post down below too just
in case you want to see it for yourself
from the original source but I'll let
you all be the judge so let's begin the
episode starts with the excursion beyond
the wall which includes John Gendry
Thoros Barrack Jorah
tormund into hound and two or three
other unknown characters ser Davos does
stay behind because he is a much of a
fighter and he would only slow down the
others the mission continues through the
north as they travel a lot of
conversations come up this is when John
offers Longclaw Jorah
on snow says that it belongs to him
since it belonged to his family but
Jorah says no you should keep it I'm not
worthy of carrying this sword my father
gave it to you for a reason
Poorman into hound have a conversation
about Brienne which the hound is amazed
at how much torment admirers and likes
bring in John and beric Dondarrion now
have one thing in common which is being
brought back to life by our lore and
they discuss what it might mean and what
their purposes might be they continue
north by trying to follow the vision the
Hound saw in the flames
finally they see the mountain shaped
like an arrowhead this is when a large
Blizzard starts and they hear a weird
growl which they can't seem to recognize
but then one of the unknown men tries to
find out what it is that's when out of
nowhere a reanimated polar bear shreds
the unknown man to pieces but because of
the heavy Blizzard no one is sure what
has happened and that's when the Beast
attacks forests of mirror the Beast
stomps for us and it gives him a few
slashes with his claws but forest is
also given the bear a few slashes with
his flaming sword when the Hound sees
the flaming sword he freezes in fear of
the flames between everyone there they
are able to kill the beast but forest is
badly wounded
berrak tries to cauterize his wounds
with his flaming sword to try and save
his life the mission must continue
though with the man down and Thoros
balancing between life and death
things are looking dire this is when
they realize with the reanimated polar
bear that means that White Walkers are
not too far and they must hurry but they
know they cannot avoid them and that's
when they run into a horde of whites and
one white Walker this is when John
battles his second white Walker one
verse one as John fights the white
Walker the others try to capture a white
but it's hard because there's other
whites also attacking at the same time
but at last they finally capture one and
either put him in Chains or gag him or
her to try to immobilize it at this
point the white army attacks all at once
without mercy and the only thing the
group can do is run they decide they
need to split up as they run to increase
our chances of survival John then
commands Gendry to run back to
eastwatch-by-the-sea and send a raven to
Daenerys to come and rescue them after
they run for a while they come together
or in frozen
like all the movement in fighting
eventually breaks up part of the ice and
the group of men are stuck in the middle
of the lake on a large piece of ice that
floats above the other smaller pieces of
ice they then make a circle and wait for
the incoming hoard of whites but the
Horde doesn't come right away so they
have to wait till they attack while all
of this is going on force of mer
eventually succumbs to his injuries and
dies barek then takes his flaming sword
and burns Thor's to avoid him coming
back as a white the night king comes out
from a foreign stares at Jon Snow and
Jon stares back without fear the lake
begins to refreeze over again and the
Horde of whites begin to rush Jon in the
group torment is almost overrun during
the attack but he is saved by a fellow
companion during this time some of them
are fighting alone and others are
fighting together it's chaos and not
looking good when all of a sudden we
hear the famous dragon roars of drogon
vissarion and Rhaegar Daenerys has come
to save the day but she must first help
fight back the whites and find the place
to land that wouldn't cause the ice to
break so her dragons or John and Company
don't drown everyone starts to get on
Rogan and Ragle as Viserion kills whites
from above john stays back fighting
whites on his own to let the group board
the Dragons John stands there basically
saying Here I am so the whites will
attack him and not his companions that
way they can make an escape as the group
is trying to escape the night king takes
his spear made out of crystal ice and he
launches it at vissarion's neck who is
flying overhead with one throw the spear
goes into the Dragons neck and brings it
down this Ariane crashes into the frozen
lake which breaks the ice making him go
into the water and sink under the water
John then runs to climb on to drag on
but he falls ones rogue on takes off and
John falls into the lake as well
Daenerys sees that John is pretty much a
goner
somehow the survivors are able to keep
the captured white with them after all
this a wounded Jon gets out of the lake
but he's in trouble because the whole
army of the Dead is there surrounding
him this is when his uncle Benjen comes
in to save him and he has his bowl of
fire and starts killing several whites
he clears out a section of the whites
and he gives John his horse so he can
get out of there and make it
back to the wall but benjin has
presumably killed while John rides off
the survivors make it back to Eastwatch
in Daenerys is traumatized and
heartbroken for the loss of her child
Viserion as any mother would be but the
mission must continue John arrives at
eastwatch-by-the-sea badly wounded he is
loaded onto a ship headed towards King's
Landing along with Daenerys and the
others the Hound is trusted with taking
the white to the dragon pit on the ship
Daenerys goes to check on the wounded
Jon Snow while checking on John he
realizes how hurt the Narus actually is
so he tries to console her which is when
Daenerys tells him he was like a son to
me it's like they had taken my son from
me
Daenerys begins to tell John I promise I
will defeat the night King John tells
Daenerys if she does indeed join him
with fighting the night king he will
bend the knee John then calls her Danny
what surprises her and Daenerys says no
one has called me Danny since my brother
John then says what would you like me to
call you my grace my Queen Daenerys says
she didn't mean it like that it's just
been a while since someone has told her
that and it was very personal
John goes on to say he would bend the
knee but he physically can because he is
so hurt this takes the nurse by surprise
again and she says you would bend a knee
what about those who follow you alright
folks I'm going to stop the video right
here for a second so I can show you
something another leak came out a few
months ago in the leak had seven pages
from the season seven script for Game of
Thrones one of those pages was this
scene between John and Daenerys on the
ship I'll put the leaked script on the
screen right now so you can pause the
video and read it if you're able to zoom
in on it according to this leaked script
all this does happen on the ship with
John and Daenerys and it does sound like
Daenerys is talking about one of her
dragons being dead which is very
interesting but once again I have no
idea if this is actually real or not but
it does back up delete that I've been
reading you if it is in fact true but
let's get back to the video after John
and Danny had their discussion on the
ship it then cuts back to the north
where the knight King orders Viserion to
be pulled from the lake the whites pull
him out of the lake using chains this
Ariane is dead but then he opens his
eyes as blue as the night Kings
then the episode ends there is more to
this leaked episode that I'm about to
read to you apparently the person who
uploaded this leak wanted to keep all
the scenes beyond the walls separate
from the other stuff because so much
happened north of the wall they didn't
want to bounce back and forth and make
it too confusing so the rest of the
video is out of order in Winterfell the
stark sisters are in a bit of an
argument Maria brings the letter she
found in Littlefinger's room and she
confronts Songza with the letter she
signed and asked her what it's about
Sean just says she had to do it to
survive so apparently what this part of
the leak is about if you haven't read
the original plot leak apparently what
happens is when Arya comes back to
Winterfell Littlefinger tries to get
Arya and songs that have bumped heads
and go against each other Littlefinger
tells Arya that Sansa wrote a letter to
her brother Rob back when he was at war
with the Lannisters
Cersei made her write a letter to Rob to
bend a knee and swear fealty to Joffrey
what songs it did do under duress from
Cersei which I think did happen back in
season one or season two and that's what
Littlefinger is trying to use to say
Sansa basically was doing whatever
Cersei wanted to try and get Ari and
sanso to go against each other later in
the episode Littlefinger tells songs are
that Jon has left them because he
doesn't care about the north
Sean's in told Littlefinger that jon is
the king and he needs to stop trying to
get into her head
Sansa tells Brienne that she needs to go
to the dragon pit to represent her since
she's the lady in Winterfell
Brienne doesn't want to go at first and
she swore an oath to protect her but
once he finds out Jaime will be there
she agrees to go she believes she will
be safe she truly believes Jaime to be
an honorable man before Daenerys leaves
Dragonstone to help Jon beyond the wall
she is seen being nervous for Jon and
Jorah but mostly for Jon Tyrion sees how
much dinero starts to care about Jon and
is uninterested in anything but news
about Jon which is when she receives a
raven from the north asking for help
when she goes to help Jon Tyrion pleads
with Daenerys he tells her she can't go
because if she goes and died then
everything they had been trying to
accomplish will be for nothing
Daenerys jumps on Drogo and leaves with
her other two dragons following right
behind her so what do you all think
about this leak do you believe any of it
if you're a longtime subscriber to my
channel then you should know most of
this has already been confirmed we know
all those characters are going to go
north together we also know there is
going to be a frozen lake that's
involved with this scene as well and
there is fires this far north that could
be Dragon Fire John does look to be
riding off on vengeance horse as well I
can't speak for everything here but some
of this does look to be true but like I
said earlier in the video I wasn't sure
how much was true so I was skeptical if
I should even make a video about this or
not
but most of you on Twitter voted yes so
I decided to make it anyway that way you
can at least hear what this was about
but comment below and let me know what
you think about it thanks for stopping
by and watching the video anyway I
really do appreciate that and I want to
give a big shout out to my patreon
supporters also I love all of you have a
good day I'll see you down below bye